what's up everyone hello hello thanks
for tuning in we're gonna be talking
about co-creation we are with Jessica
and Welker thanks for joining us on the
show appreciate it
Jessica definitely does a lot of shows
herself as well you can follow her we'll
have some links in the bio for you to
check out as well so we are at the
Berkeley marina right now it's quite
beautiful it's really nice here and
we're gonna be talking about co-creation
because of a lot of reasons one of them
is that it's really important to figure
out who that self is who I am who you
are who you are and find people to
co-create with you've done a lot of
conversations on co-creation I have done
a lot of conversations on co-creation
and I love synchronicity and the fact
that Ellen I are standing here
side-by-side right now in this moment to
me as a manifestation of co-creation of
putting your desires and intentions out
there into the universe letting it go
going with the flow seeing where it
takes you and ìletís to this moment so
how can you not love that yeah and
there's there's this whole weird sort of
culture with C ult cult or culture
because it's very cult-like there's very
little people that are that are pushing
you were just pushing your cousin Jordan
to to question everything question your
surroundings question your your you the
way that people lock down the same
conventional path that so many others do
what is your life path and and you were
pushing that and it's so important to
have more people why why did it why does
the conversation about someone that
works in a retail or service industry
position to to to just ask them you know
what do you what would you rather be
doing with your time you know what what
job or skill are you going to retrain to
with automation Age coming why does that
have to be a philosophical conversation
it's an i it's just it's it because we
label it that way we label it as some
like kooky weirdo conversation and the
normal one is oh how are you Oh
good okay so to know who we are to be
sovereign will help us attract other
really sovereign beings for us to
co-create different endeavors and
projects into the world that bring
utility value creativity yeah I think
there's an interesting dynamic
especially for women something that I've
experienced myself is that being told
what to think how to think what to feel
what to believe and I'm not feeling so
centered in myself and in my own belief
system so I was I was believing what
these other men were telling me and so
for me to finally get really centered in
Who I am and feeling so confident in
that and honoring and trusting in my own
intuition and all of that has changed my
entire life but also being a sovereign
of my life and that's something that
really really experienced the last
couple of months is that like I own
everything that's happened in my life
I'm taking full responsibility
everything is my choice nothing has been
done to me I have allowed all of it to
come to me for whatever reason it is and
there might be some distinctions I know
people have that but what if the open
mic open but it's okay but if you really
just owned like this is my life and this
is my responsibility and I can create
anything that I want and I understand
because I was very much in the victim
state I have plenty of stories sob
stories to tell anybody and I used to do
that but when I understood the
importance of owning my life
and knowing that I can create anything
that I want and then I can co-create
with someone again that's why I'm
standing here right now and I mean this
really fantastic conversation and a
beautiful day with this beautiful man I
mean that is what's possible when we're
willing to take hold of our life and
stop putting the responsibility on other
people's plates it's not there it's ours
so that's how I feel about sovereignty I
like that that also kind of takes the
ball and moves it into our court that it
is totally in my own control to live
whatever life and that I that I want to
envision and just the fact that we don't
future author what we want to do that
day that week that month that year with
our lives and who we want in our lives
both in the creative endeavors we pursue
and the romantic endeavors we pursue but
we need to author those futures that we
want to see and in order to do so we
have to envision them and go through
that process
and I like how you said that we're not
focusing on to all of the different
things that each one of us has each one
of us has traumatic things of happened
that has happened to us but so okay next
is another really exciting topic okay
this one this one's really exciting for
me because I had a wait should we talk
about what what kind of relationship
you'd want though yeah yeah sure so you
know Jessica asked you know she asked me
a really good question which was what
would be the most high vibe relationship
that you could envision and it took me a
little bit to think about an answer and
the answer was
extremely spiritual emotional
intellectual sexual and at the highest
sort of vibration to the point of where
we're just amplify each other to godlike
states and we're building the future
together co-creating and so you know
Jessica herself has like a list a huge
list of yeah I mean it's it's really
powerful it's like a long list of things
that she's looking for in people that
she co creates with and I think that's
really important if you're not going to
make a list you're gonna just have
whoever show up and and that's a good
really good way to manifest what you
want is to have this sort of to have
that sort of list
okay so in the past right we've been in
relationships and we've been in this
kind of stagnation right we've affirm me
when I was looking at potential partners
I'd be thinking about the potentiality
of a longevity of a relationship that
longevity like okay is this something is
this something I can see 10 years from
now 15 years from I'm trying and I was
like wow this is an old paradigm that
doesn't work anymore because I keep
evolving and shifting and transforming
so much that no longer fits my paradigm
so what is something that I can
co-create with somebody that's never
been done before has never been existed
and that's something that I posed to
Ellen like what is the most high five
high consciousness relationship that you
could create and for me it's about
co-creation it's about doing something
together that lifts us up into a state
of ecstasy when we are at the highest
level that we can and we will blast each
other to the next level into the next
level and then we assess at that point
is this something where we continue to
co-create or have we reached our apex
and we're ready to move forward with
other new partners so so it's totally
different and I love it and I feel
enlivened and motivated and inspired and
excited because because it has a
different feel right that is like we're
not signing up for something that's like
okay so we're going to date for two
years and then maybe this will happen
maybe this or maybe it won't it's like
no right now in this moment this is how
I'm feeling and just
going from that please yeah this leads
us into the the story and I thought this
that you know this is a really
interesting story because it just
happened recently where I myself was
very deeply believing in my ability to
oh yeah I'm a total in the moment kind
of guy and I'm totally cool with what
with with just being in the moment
that's my thing I love it when I'm with
people with someone and and I don't have
to worry about if tomorrow is gonna
happen with them or the next week or the
next year or whatever but you know when
I was with Jessica I was very hesitant
to to endeavor into into romantic
endeavors with Jessica because I was
like well wait a second now I'm all
concerned about whether or not this is
going to last more than a day that this
is going to be a year or whatever it may
be and Jessica was like well hold on a
second I thought you were more in the
moment so it was really interesting that
I you know that we kind of recognized
the fact that I was in that state and I
know you know I challenged myself to get
to get out of that state into a next
ASUS a moment-to-moment ecstatic and
that was really powerful for me because
it shifted a lot of the way that I feel
about things and and Jessica and I kind
of had a had an interesting now way of
perceiving each moment-to-moment
together rather than a need for some
sort of 100% certainty with what the
future is going to be like and that's a
really interesting way of perceiving the
world I like that a lot and and I like
that we owned what was coming up for us
so we both have had triggers that like
we've said like yeah let's do this thing
this is really exciting and then we get
into this moment where something arises
that gets triggered in us a fear or
something like that which to me means
it's Rafer to be transcended
so for us to own it acknowledge it speak
our truth and then move forward and it
is just amazing it's not staying
underneath the surface is not building
this tension it's this ability to be
radically honest and sharing what's
coming up for us owning it that it
hours and then yeah and such and then
there's this sort of point about the way
that yeah not only are you going to
admit and take responsibility for
yourself but I got the I got I got this
this last part about the way that
whoever you end up picking Jessica was
like yeah sure so you can have a one
plus one equals two or you can have a
one plus one equals a million and
thought that was pretty interesting I
also thought that I also thought that if
this this analogy that we sort of have
been discussing the last last like week
or so it's just that if you find
yourself as a sprinkler in a lawn and
the person that you're co-creating with
is also a sprinkler and a lawn and if
you guys are kind of stacked on top of
each other in the exact same location
you're gonna water the same patches of
grass but if your two sprinklers that
are pretty far away from each other you
can water parts of yeah you can cross
pollinate you so the so Jessica
sprinkler is located in an area of grass
that's a little further from mine in
many ways and so she's watering peat
patches of grass and I'm learning from
her watering those patches of grass cuz
my sprinkler can't reach there and vice
verse is true with my sprinkler and so
we found that analogy to be very
interesting and we can see where exactly
it is some people prefer to have
sprinklers all stacked on top of each
other and that's great maybe they end up
growing greener grass and taller grass
and stuff like that in those radiuses
right but to me the thought of us cross
pollinating and the water that he can
reach on my side that I don't even see
is possible so what would be dry right
by my sprinkler now he can water it and
nurture it and give it some life and
same thing for me that I can bring light
over and water refreshment into these
areas in his area that he cannot reach
so to me that's just so much more
beautiful is that this cross-pollination
kind of
idea that that well we all work together
and as co-creators and co-partners that
we can create something a much beautiful
lawn that everything is covered
yeah and that that also speaks to the
whole color wheel idea that you know
Jessica was like you know my job's not
to be mother Teresa to go into the
streets of Calcutta and going directly
if that's why a lot of people on the
streets of San Francisco that are
hundred thousand dollar-a-year
developers designers whatever that
they're not going and doing direct
one-on-one help to people that are
homeless they're these different colors
on the color wheel there are certain
people that want to go and do that type
of work the direct one-on-one homeless
work there are other people that want to
potentially do some sort of overarching
strategy around what can be done on a
raising consciousness level across the
planet in order to raise the vibe
there's this it's it's very so different
people have different colors the same
thing with their co-creative partners
that they're endeavoring with different
flavors and no color is more important
than the other so understanding that
that every contribution matters it's
just finding what brings you joy so if
you're picking a cause because you feel
sorry for them that actually does not
help the situation in my opinion from
what I understand it's when you find
something that brings you joy which when
you find something that brings you joy
and lightens you up that is doing making
big change in big transformation the
world and focusing on that and so for
myself I used to be overwhelmed because
there's so many things to help there's
so many causes or so many people in need
where do I even begin and what I'm
understanding is like my color is a
different color and I'm able to stay in
that color and it raises the vibration
and that's my contribution so
understanding that what brings you joy
what brings you life what makes it feel
so beautiful to be a part of rather than
feeling sorry for somebody or feeling
bad for a situation that doesn't change
the
but it's all important every color is
important
there's no one is more important than
the other we all have our cause we all
have our colors it also brings us back
to the point once oven shop sovereign
tree at the very beginning you give me a
sovereign being and really figure out
what your mission your purpose is on
this planet what your gift is and what
you're giving away if you can go through
that process and figure it out inspire
young kids to figure it out fast then we
will figure out where you put where you
place on the color wheel and we'll be
symphony together of notes all seven and
a half billion of us on this planet all
right last thoughts last thoughts
co-creation Jessica wants to build a
city that that has the Divine Feminine
energy yeah the Divine Feminine is
coming everybody so and this is a
different different flavor different
vibe than feminism this is a very very
different I explain the difference Oh
put me on the spot here
um so Divine Feminine I believe is one
that's loving it's accepting it's
honoring everybody in their life that
there is nothing that is better than or
less than that everything is honored and
available to people in my experience of
being able to channel a place where the
vine feminine comes from they are joyful
they are happy they're loving they are
grateful they are wanting to heal
wanting to help people and that is the
vibe that I resonate with very very much
and so I'm learning that what I resonate
with and we've got Marco Polo which is a
whole other great conversation to have
multi will co-create a video about Marco
but what resonates for you and
understanding that something that
resonates more deeply for you isn't
actually tuning into your soul so to me
feminism it is been a way of showing up
and it's had its purpose and it's had
its place and it has been meant to be
what it is every every step and I'm
there I support women I'm so much it's a
little start you know we'll unpack that
more in the videos to come we got a lot
more to unpack like we're talking about
Marco Polo there's so much more to
unpack about these different analogies
that we've been discussing and I've been
very profound so this has been a bit on
co-creation it's been a lot of fun
chatting we'll Jessica's gonna be down
in Ecuador for a while and then she'll
be back so we're really excited to
continue making cool content about
things like co-creation again remember
be sovereign go and figure out what your
gift is to this world go and bring it to
this world shatter through the fears and
anxieties that we have take the risks go
and be centric going do your thing and
also pick your color take your color
I wanna brings you joy yeah take your
color and go and make that impact on the
world
don't just consume this content go and
create you guys know that go and build
after you watch this go and write go and
go and make a video go and start a
company go do your thing go and build
into the world thanks for tuning in if
you guys had a good time show us some
love with some comments below let us
know your thoughts thanks for tuning in
much love peace